[موسيقى]
مساء الخير هل صحيح انه الولايات المتحده
كحكومة بتحب الاسلام ولا بتكره الاسلام زي
موقفها وموقفها من الاسلام زي اي ديانه
اخرى والهدف الاساسي لاي حكومه للولايات
المتحده ل 200 سنه فاتوا هو حاجه واحده بس
الحفاظ على امبراطوريه امريكيه عظيمه
تراكم الثروات لاصحابها وتحصل على اكبر
قدر ممكن من ثروات الشعوب الاخرى لكن تم
توظيف
الاسلام لصالح الولايات المتحده في مواقف
كثيره جدا يعني بدايه من الحرب العالميه
الثانيه وادرك صانع القرار في البيت
الابيض ان المسلمين عندهم طاقه شديده جدا
جايه نتيجه الايمان بدينهم بشكل كبير جدا
وبالتالي قرروا انه يستغل هذا الايمان
الكبير جدا وهذا الحماس من جانب عدد كبير
من المسلمين لصالح الولايات المتحده بدل
ما ان ينقلب
ضدهم على سبيل المثال رئيس امريكا
ايزنهاور في مطع الخمسينات قرر انه انه
انه يجاب نفوذ القوميه العربيه ونفوذ
الزعيم الكبير جمال عبد الناصر باستغلال
ايه ما يقدرش نضربه بالقوه العسكريه الضغط
عليه اقتصاديا ما كانش نافع فقرر انه لا
يفل الحديد الا الحديد انه يستغل الجماعات
الاسلاميه في ضرب جمال عبد النصر وافكاره
وبالفعل ابتدا يدعم جماعه الاخوان
المسلمين وغيرها من الجماعات علشان تحاصر
القوميه العربيه على سبيل المثال في سنه
53 استقبل سعيد الدكتور سعيد رمضان اللي
هو جوز بنت الشيخ حسن البنا مع مجموعه
بتكون من 15 عالم مسلم اخر من مختلف بلدان
العالم والزياره كانت تبدو ان هي للمؤتمر
اسلامي لكن دعوه الرئيس الامريكي اللي
معروفه واللي تصورت وموجوده صور الشيخ
سعيد مع بقيه الوفد مع الرئيس الامريكي
داخل البيت الابيض الحقيقه كانت بتنظم
المخابرات الامريكيه وكان الهدف منه البحث
انه يستغل ويستطلع راي هؤلاء العلماء
المؤثرين في امكانيه مساعدتهم في
امرين مد
النفوس الروسي الاتحاد السوفيتي وقتها
الشيوعيه ويستغلو هم يستغلوا المسلمين من
ناحيه دينيه في انه يرفضوا هذا المد
الحاجه الثانيه وقف النفوذ الكبير والصعود
لجمال عبد النصر والقوميه العربيه اللي
كانت الى حد كبير قريبه من الاتحاد
السوفي ايزنهاور اللي كتب الكلام ده بشكل
يعني غير مباشر في مذكراته وحاول حتى انه
يستغل المكانه الدينيه للسعوديه عشان يحل
محل جمال عبد الناصر او ان
هي تبقى المعادل لجمال عبد الناصر عبر عنه
وخد موقف مشابه من رؤساء امريكان تانيين
في مواقف مختلفه ابرزهم رونال ريجن اللي
في سنه
1979 قرر انه يستغل او قدم اشهر صور
التعاون ما بين الاداره الامريكيه وما بين
الاسلام او التعبير الدقيق اشهر صور
استغلال الاداره الامريكيه لحماس المسلمين
بحيث يصب في قضاياها حصل ايه سنه 79 ان
الاتحاد السوفيتي غزى افغانستان في ظروف
معقده يصعب التعرض ليها دلوقتي قرر
الولايات المتحده ان هي تستغ الفرصه و
وتقضي على الامبراطوريه المنافسه اللي هي
الاتحاد السوفيتي كان القضاء عليها من
مدخل الاس الاسلام والمسلمين واثاره مشاعر
الدينيه عنده وبالتالي ابتدى يتسرب او
تسمح بتسلل ما سميه وقتها بالمجاهدين
وبدعم من السعوديه ومن دول اخرى ومنهم مصر
هؤلاء المجاهدين كانوا بمدهم المخابرات
الامريكيه بالسلاح واحيانا بالتمويل وكان
الهدف عند المجاهدين بيعتقدوا ان هم
بيحاربوا من اجل رف رفع رايه الاسلام
دفاعا عن بلد مسلمه ضد الكفر الشيوعيين
بينما كان هدف السي اي اي او المخابرات
الامريكيه القضاء تماما على القوى العظمى
الثانيه وهي الاتحاد السوفيتي وهو ما تحقق
لاحقا بالفعل وادى الى انهيار الاتحاد
السوفيتي الرؤساء الامريكان التاليين سعوا
برض لتوظيف الاسلام والمسلمين بدرجات
مختلفه وكانوا حريصين ان يظهروا اكبر قدر
ممكن من اللياقه في التعبير عن مواقفهم من
الاسلام وحريصين على مقابلتهم جدا
للمسلمين علشان دايما يكونوا في صفهم
ويستغلو ويوظف حين حين يحتاجون الى
هذا الى مساعدتهم مثلا على سبيل المثال
بيل كلنتن هو واحد من اكثر الرؤساء
الامريكان جاذبيه
وذكاء في التعامل مع القضايا الداخليه
والخارجيه كان اول رئيس امريكي يستنى سنه
استضافه المسلمين في افطار طبعا زعماء
الجاليه الاسلاميه في افطار عام داخل
البيت الع
تاب والتزم بهذه السنه طوال سنوات وجوده
في البيت الابيض اللي هي الثمان سنوات وفي
السنه الاخيره لتوليه
الرئاسه يعني في الافطار الاخير القى خطبه
مؤثره جدا عن علاقته بالاسلام
والمسلمين تحدث فيها عن ابنته الوحيده
اللي كانت بتطرح عليه اسئله كتيره لما
كانت بتدرس كورس عن الحضاره الاسلاميه
والدين الاسلامي وبيقول للحاضرين ان هو
اجاب على بعض الاسئله لكنه هو وزوجته
هيلاري كلينتون اللي مرشحه الان لتولي
يعني مرشحه لان منصب رئاسه الولايات
المتحده لا يستطيعون الاجابه على كل
الاسئله نيابه عنهم وبيدعو ان هم يقدموا
اكبر قدر ممكن من الاجابات لجمهور
الولايات المتحده وغيرها من باقي الشعوب
وقال ان هناك ايه محدده دائما كانت
تستوقفه وبيحب ان يسمع اليها والايه ديت
اللي موجوده في سوره في سوره الحجرات
واللي ربنا سبحانه وتعالى بيقول فيها يا
ايها الناس انا خلقناكم من ذكر وانثى
وجعلناكم شعوبا وقبائله لتعارفوا ان
اكرمكم عند الله اتقاكم ان الله عليم
خبير جورج بوش الابن اللي تعرضت الولايات
المتحده في عهده الى 11 سبتمبر حادث 11
سبتمبر اللي زلزل الولايات المتحده كان
حريص حتى في عز الازمه دي قلا يغضب
المسلمين ولا ينجرف للمقالات او ما كتب في
وسائل الاعلام ان من ضرب الولايات المتحده
هم المسلمين فكان حريص بعدها بعده ايام
يكون في المركز الاسلامي واشنطن بيقول
الناس كان بيع من زعماء المسلمين ان كل
اصدقائنا ومواطنين المسلمين في نفس الخندق
الذي نقف فيه ومصدوم بنفس الصدمه الرهيبه
مما فعله قله لا تعبر عن قيم الاسلام ولما
حب يعبر عن مصير هؤلاء
ارتكبوا هذه الجريمه لم يجد الا الايه
الكريمه اللي هي الايه العاشره من سوره
الروم ثم كان عاقبه الذين اساؤوا السوء ان
كذبوا بايات الله وكانوا بها
يستهزئون الحقيقه انه بعد جورج بوش الابن
لما جاه اوباما اوباما قرر باعتباره مسلما
سابقا وظل مقيدا كتلميذ مسلم في المدارس
في مدارس اندونيسيا حتى راعه ابتدائي اراد
ان يدخل التاريخ من اوسع ابوابه هو ازاله
هذا التوتر التاريخي ما بين الولايات
المتحده والمسلمين وبانه يجعل
الاسلام احد وسائل الحل واحد
وسائل يعني احد يبه عامل اضافي لتعاون
الدول الاسلاميه بالمسلمين وبان سياسته
الخارجيه كلها من اول يوم على استماله
الاسلام والمسلم
لكنه فشل في ذلك فشلا يعا وده له اسباب
وطول شرحها وتستحق مننا حلقه اخرى ان شاء
الله اشكركم والى اللقاء